sie hauen alles raus im training drei
tage vor dem nächsten spiel irakern
scham sia uran oscars malaysia das ganze
afghanische frauen fußballteam an diesem
kühlen donnerstagabend in melbourne
australien jeff hawkins hat als profi in
der englischen premier league gespielt
16 mal für die walisische
nationalmannschaft er ist ein erfahrener
trainer diese erfahrungen jedoch ist nur
die mädchen sind wirklich nachsicht
haben aber mir ihre namen zu merken und
richtig auszusprechen ich gebe mir mühe
und liebe trotzdem ständig daneben dann
lachen sie über mich aber das ist
schon sehr dribbelt sich durch die
stangen dribbelt sich durchs leben
aufgewachsenen einen kleinen dorf in den
bergen afghanistans kamen sie mit 19 in
die hauptstadt fürs studium und für den
fußball
in kabul habe ich zum ersten mal in
einem richtigen team gespielt
direkt nach dem ersten spiel haben sie
mich zur nationalmannschaft geholt weil
ich so gut war und sieben tore gemacht
habe
dann sollte ich gegen tadschikistan
spielen aber daraus wurde leider nichts
mehr weil die taliban kamen sie haben
mir mein erstes länderspiel gestohlen
von klein auf hat schauen sie es geliebt
gegen den ball zu treten mit ihren
brüdern den cousins den jungs aus der
nachbarschaft konnte sie mühelos
mithalten ein mädchen behauptet den ball
und sich selbst schauen sie rate nicht
wie wichtig dass eines tages werden
würde jetzt weiß ich
nur weil ich gut fußball spielen kann
bin ich hier in freiheit fußball ist
alles
die gesamte frauen-nationalmannschaft
afghanistans hat asyl in australien
gefunden der sport war ihr ticket in die
freiheit der fußball rettete ihr leben
nachdem er es sogar erst in gefahr
gebracht hat
kabul im august vergangenen jahres hals
über kopf ziehen die nato truppen ab
überlassen das land und seine menschen
den taliban die bringen afghanistan die
herrschaft des schreckens zurück vor
allem für frau
als die taliban zurück kam haben wir
gewusst jetzt ist alles vorbei wir
mädchen können nicht mehr vor die tür
jede freiheit ist weg wir können nicht
mehr zur schule wir können nicht mehr
fußball spielen wir sind nicht mehr
sicher es war ein alptraum und wir alle
haben die hoffnung verloren
nur raus aus afghanistan viele fassen in
den dramatischen tagen diesen entschluss
auch chancen
ich sah die wilden taliban über ein sie
schlugen uns schossen um sich
verbreiteten angst und schrecken wir
haben drei oder vier tage am flughafen
ausgehalten das war unsere einzige
chance und als ich dann tatsächlich
irgendwann in diesem militärflugzeugs
saß war ich geschockt und dachte weißt
du getan
ich wusste nicht ob ich jemals
zurückkommen und ich wusste auch nicht
wohin ich gehe
melbourne ist es geworden wie ein
anderer planet das große los in einer
unmenschlichen lotterie ausgerechnet
australien sonst für seine rigorose
asylpolitik bekannt gewährte visa für
afghanistans fußballerinnen das
ermöglichte die flucht in letzter minute
sie durften kommen sie dürfen bleiben
kam sie ja und auch uran ist die beiden
sind mit spielerinnen freundinnen
inzwischen wie schwestern das leben in
der ferne verbindet sie teilen sorgen
hoffnungen sehnsüchte
einkaufen am liebsten im afghanischen
laden um die ecke
kochen am liebsten wie zu hause
sie haben es mit burger und fritten
versucht australisch eben und landeten
doch wieder bei knoblauch reis gemüse
lang afghanisch eben die bei mutter
als ich das rezept hier zum ersten mal
gekocht habe dachte ich mama ich
vermisse dich so sehen also
wenn es eines tages möglich ist wieder
nach hause zu meiner familie zu fliegen
dann bin ich sofort unterwegs
neu beginnen heißt auch alles
zurücklassen es war eine schicksalsfrage
deren antwort keinen aufschub duldete
jetzt oder nie ihre eltern haben sie
ermutigt zu gehen aber es war schwer für
alle und das ist es bis heute
jedes mal wenn ich mama anrufen will sie
dass sich die kamera einschalten das
internet ist leider oft schlecht aber
sie sagt ich will dich sehen
so weit weg in jeder hinsicht der satz
klingt profan und sagt doch alles in
australien können afghanische frauen
noch fußballspiel chance kann es
wirklich
das erste tor des tages gehört
melbourne victory der größte klub des
landes hat dafür gesorgt dass das
afghanische team eine lizenz für die
unterste liga bekam dort ist die
konkurrenz nicht allzu gross heute gibt
es ein klares 8 zu 1 aber sie wollen
mehr einen platz auf der internationalen
bühne als offizielles nationalteam
afghanistans der fußball-weltverband tut
sich schwer
[Applaus]
die fifa akzeptiert dass afghanische
männer team weiterhin und weigert sich
gleichzeitig das frauen team offiziell
anzuerkennen das ist absurd wenn ich
viel für menschenrechte ernst bedeutet
dieser exil mannschaft hier anzuerkennen
wäre ein wichtiges signal der
unterstützung für die rechte der frauen
in afghanistan
sie spielen für ein land das nicht mehr
ihres sein darf und sie spielen mit
erfolg
schauen sie macht auch das letzte tor
des tages ihr rechter fuß ist einfach
ein hammer sie verdammt ihn ihr leben
[Musik]
[Applaus]